shots fired shots fired suspect is
shooting a North Carolina man is killed
by police after firing shots at passing
cars prompting the lockdown of a nearby
Middle School
suspect is actively firing at us we have
no launch site
it happened on March 27th in Raleigh
North Carolina just before seven o'clock
that morning a 9-1-1 call came in
reporting a man firing a gun at Vehicles
near Legion Magnet Middle School minutes
after the call came in officers arrived
on the scene to find the suspect later
identified as Jorge Luis Vega lasama
before First Responders arrived
investigators say Vega lasama shot two
vehicles including one that had children
inside of it once on the scene three
officers got out of their squad cars and
approached the suspect
just like
four times
[Music]
we have
police released multiple body camera and
dash camera recordings of the incident
where officers can be heard saying Vega
lasama is firing at them
suspect is actively firing at us we have
no one site dash camera video shows
several angles of officers responding to
the gunfire
this is
eventually officers returned fire
striking vagalasama Vega lasama was
later pronounced dead as a result of his
injuries all three officers involved in
the shooting are now placed on
administrative leave as the
investigation into the shooting is still
underway reporting for long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie